[Music]
party you taking care of yourself now oh
yeah I want to point but you are you
know party on that slightly quite a
serious note we've known you for a long
time and we care about you and you've
been in rehab for what is it eight nine
months yeah but you've been sober that
long total in my life about 14 years but
in a row eight months eight months yeah
and you know what's supposed to taste
that before there's that Boston sarcasm
it's very supportive but ya know III
came out and um I stopped doing I was
doing heroin which is a bad drug to do
it when you can't do that it takes your
soul away they're really nice and
Bologna
it also takes your abs away but so they
suggested a trainer for a while so I'm
working with a trainer and I like people
in shape and healthy but they say stupid
things they just if you say something
stupid I get aggravated I'm first month
or so I'm off heroin I'm just trained a
real good shape unbelievable
caught young Brad Pitt looking I mean
not gay or anything but I like me I was
like good cute kid and he sees me kind
of like out of it what's the matter
yeah you know may I be honest with you I
was hard on heroin I remember the high
of heroin I don't have any substitute
for anything and the kid I swear to God
he says it's heroin good he goes uh why
don't you try running
that's what he said and that's what my
eye starts to put I don't know what
you're talking about does run a runner
sighs just as good as a heroin hi
oh yeah yeah have you tried heroin
[Music]
now I want to argue with the guy mad
yeah yeah I stopped in the middle of my
third squat brush to go
I got you tried every goes no I go okay
well you're not qualified to be in this
argument then are you that's a negative
way oh no no no cuz I've done heroin and
I've run it's not even close come on do
me a favor so we could up as a goof
try heroin try no III so now get into
arguing this healthy kid about heroin
I'd say you guys know try running
apparently have to run more than 20 feet
to get the high I started running I get
like get out a little bit on my eighth
mile I call the guy but hey hey is this
van Williams fan it's already I'm on my
eight points at your arm on the eighth
mile when exactly does it start to feel
like heroin to be funny if like he took
my advice in two years later I see him
under a bridge you were right
well you're right you're right Ronnie's
not even close can I borrow 20 bucks now
I gotta run yeah
[Applause]